tu es dessus par un pigeon lors de la
marche républicaine et françois hollande
devant lac est ici veut prendre sa
revanche
merci merci françois alors c'est très
simple le jeu très simple gilles verdez
va s'élancer gilles est ce que vous êtes
bien l'attacher mon chéri j'espère cyril
est ce que parce qu'en fait j'ai
confiance quand vous cyril est ce que
vous pouvez vérifier leur demander que
je suis bien attacher pas c'est quand
même un peu bizarre mais alors dans les
sirh et à ce qu'il est vraiment bien la
tâche et je vous jure que c'est vrai ça
me fait peur franchement oui
vous êtes sûr vous avez vérifié en régie
sur 1 on voudrait inquiétez pas j'ai
alors je peux vous demander autre chose
syrie comme quoi il devra partir comme
la dernière fois vous pourrez faire un
décompte
d'accord vous voulez mon angoisse j'ai
donc je vous aime trop manger où ça va
mon sourire vous aime aussi je vous l ai
dit non mais je ne voulais pas qu'on
voulait pas qu'on annule non sans
déconner la charles pas non si je suis
bien attacher givers des cadeaux à fatou
on a fait un repas en tête à tête les
yeux dans les yeux sans bouger il avance
sur les foutus partout le coût et les
odeurs et pourquoi je sais pas on en
oublier de manger c'est comme ça parfois
vous êtes hypnotisé on a en outre que
les techno tease et par où enfin tous -
apparel vous êtes sûrs qu'ils avaient
pas messmer derrière vous et avec des
patous été comme ça ça nous en fait je
pense que a été très fatigués surtout
non sans doute web l'aï mangé quoi des
sushi bâ des sushis regardez il dit des
soucis à régler tout content de garder
son chien ces gens je suis chez brault
dit mot pâtissent tu sais que fatou fait
une soirée sushis à son bac 5 4 je vais
décroît je veux pas voir ça [ __ ] moi
non plus
[ __ ] voyez les corps
[Applaudissements]
avant j'y vais avec
très mauvaise idée c'est une sorte de
sous l'habile a donc il va arrêter quand
il est en dessous la villa oui il va
être extrêmement langue de bois
ouais c'est un mauvais débatteurs bon
animateur
j'y crois pas une seconde c'est pas vrai
il a toujours assumé le second degré
snes qui l'a présentée j'ai surtout
d'être intéressante parce qu'on habite a
été l'âge il était super potable voilà
on affiche une baisse qui va bientôt
parce que c'est lancé qui va bientôt
sauter lyon mais ses paumes tournées
vers des géants ont basculé sans latence
arrête un patient montèrent gilles
gentais merci est ce qu'on attendait
oui oui je voudrais vous pensez être
vous êtes à 60 mètres de hauteur la ji
lutins je pense à tout ce nom ça vous
curieusement que tu ne pense plus à rien
le challenge il est à 3 et en
fournissent une émission aux montres
l'émission pour fournir des jobs à nos
enfants une émission pour mieux intégrer
les jeunes des quartiers
quand je vois ça franchement j'ai mal à
ma france
[Applaudissements]
enfin ce qu'on veut ce qu'il admire mais
je n'imagine d'hier soir je vous l'uriné
dans ce lieu écoute fattouche et balaban
france
je ne suis pas bien pas tout je pense
qu'il a coupé la télé la vie de michel
sardou dirigeants sont tous élèves tombe
et laisse tomber
notes genève elle était sûre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]